[Applaudissements]
merci
merci à tous alors vous voyez
effectivement que florence et moi nous
sommes vraiment sur la même longueur
d'onde on s'est même habillé pareil ce
matin why he man alors c'est vrai que
quand je vois la pépinière de talents
qui est derrière moi j'ai envie de
plagier valéry giscard d'estaing
quand il disait à la gauche vous n'avez
pas le monopole du coeur
et bien moi j'ai envie de dire à en
marche
vous n'avez pas le monopole du
renouvellement le renouvellement est là
[Applaudissements]
alors mes chers amis je salue tous ceux
qui sont ici rassemblés le président du
sénat gérard larcher
[Applaudissements]
je salue notre chef de file que nous
voulons amener au gouvernement de la
france françois baroin
[Applaudissements]
je salue les locaux de l'étape notre
président de groupe christian jacob à la
seine et marne
le président de la commission des
finances gilles caennaise
et je n'oublie évidemment pas le
secrétaire général du mouvement les
républicains bernard accoyer
[Applaudissements]
le président de la fédération de paris
philippe goujon le trésorier daniel
fasquelle le responsable du projet eric
woerth
les présidents de région xavier bertrand
philippe richert pts et tout ce que je
ne vois pas dans cette salle mais qui y
sont sûrement longerait saluer tous les
parlementaires christian cambon le
président de la fédération du val de
marne
je m'arrête là et ils m'excuseront parce
que sinon je vais en oublier et je vais
faire beaucoup de déçus donc merci à
tous les parlementaires qui sont là
merci à vous tous d'être ici aujourd'hui
c'est un jour important c'est un jour
fondateur la droite et le centre lance
la bataille du projet pour la france et
les français unis et fiers de leur
valeur d'ailleurs j'en profite et je
vous demande de d'avoir une pensée pour
jean christophe lagarde qui a
malheureusement le président de l'udps
et y qui a malheureusement eu un
accident cardiaque cette semaine et qui
a été hospitalisée qui ne pouvais pas
être avec nous aujourd'hui je voudrais
qu'on l'applaudisse très faim parce que
l'unité de la droite et du centre
ça a été très bien dit par nos jeunes
c'est l'un de nos plus puissant atout
alors oui nous sommes unis nous sommes
fiers de nos valeurs je vais vous dire
pour nous ici au parc floral
les choses sont claires
nos convictions passe avant nos
ambitions
[Applaudissements]
alors beaucoup d'entre vous ont eu le
sentiment à juste titre que la campagne
présidentielle avait été escamoté que la
confrontation des projets n'avaient pas
eu lieu
et vous avez raison alors bon on a
échappé au pire
les français ont fait barrage à
l'extrême droite
nous avons désormais un président de la
république et un gouvernement mais
certains voudraient nous faire croire
que ça y est tout est fini eh bien non
le cycle électoral n'est pas terminée
voici venir le troisième tour le
troisième tour des élections nationales
et ce troisième tour c'est les
législatives
c'est le temps de choisir le programme
de gouvernement que nous voulons pour la
france et je suis venu vous dire j'ai la
conviction qu'après une campagne
présidentielle où rien ne s'est passé
comme prévu
et bien tout reste ouvert pour les
législatives
emmanuel macron a nommé un premier
ministre de droite
eh bien allons jusqu'au bout de ses
désirs les plus fous
donnons lui une majorité de la droite et
du centre a couvert de mortiers de la
droite et du centre pour mettre en
oeuvre le projet de la droite et du
centre
[Applaudissements]
il a mis un pied dans l'eau en au moins
un premier ministre de droite
eh ben on dans le beignet il se dit en
marche et bien en ont long en ont le
jusqu'au bout du chemin
alors je le sais tout au long de cette
campagne on va vous dire que le clivage
droite gauche n'a plus de sens qu'il est
dépassé usé terminée quelle erreur
quelle faute laissé en marche avec comme
seul opposant l'extrême droite et
l'extrême gauche pas question je ne
crois pas à la confusion des idées je ne
crois pas à l'effacement des valeurs le
clivage droite gauche
il est présent dans la mémoire de notre
nation dans son histoire depuis la
révolution française
il a un sens une nécessité
ce n'est pas une question partisane
ce n'est pas une histoire de sectarisme
c'est une question de vision
la vision que la droite porte pour la
france et les français n'est pas la même
que la vision de la gauche
n'ayons pas peur des différences elles
sont le sel de la démocratie n'ayons pas
peur du débat un débat constructif
n'ayons pas peur de souhaiter une
cohabitation apaisée sereine
une cohabitation qui ne bloque pas les
institutions mais qui va faire avancer
le pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
n'en n'ayant pas peur d'affirmer qui
nous sommes et soyons en fiers nous
sommes de droit nous sommes du centre
nous en sommes fiers nous sommes fiers
de notre histoire nous sommes fiers de
nos valeurs comme l'écrivent et honoré
de balzac un longue à venir
demande un long passé à cette aune le
gouvernement n'a pas un longue à venir
selon passé il fait notre richesse ils
expliquent qu'ils nous sommes nous
sommes une famille politique forte
structurantes enracinée dans l'histoire
de france lié à la grandeur de la france
nos valeurs c'est la liberté c'est
l'autorité c'est le patriotisme c'est la
transmission c'est la justice ce sont
les valeurs qui ont marqué les plus
beaux moments de l'histoire de notre
pays
je pense aux espoirs militaire de
d'artagnan au siège de la rochelle aux
réformes napoléonienne je pense à la
défense du capitaine dreyfus face à
l'ignominie à l'appel du 18 juin 1940 en
passant par la création de la sécurité
sociale par le conseil national de la
résistance je pense à la construction
européenne ou à l'émancipation des
femmes et oui rappelons le
l'émancipation des femmes
c'est les gouvernements de droite qu'ils
les ont obtenus
[Musique]
et plus proche de nous je pense à la
reconnaissance de la responsabilité de
l'état français dans la déportation des
juifs
je pense à l'opposition à la guerre en
irak
je pense au grenelle de l'environnement
cher mode alors notre histoire elle est
liée à l'histoire de la république les
gaullistes les libéraux les radicaux les
démocrates chrétiens toutes ses forces
de la droite et du centre se sont battus
ensemble elles sont les artisans de
cette république forte et efficace que
le général de gaulle appelait de ses
voeux en 1958 en fondant la vème
république la vème république c'est la
république d'un peuple indépendant et
fier qui doit être protégé par
l'autorité de l'état
guidés par la mission fondatrice de
l'école
stimulé par la passion de la liberté
nous sommes les héritiers de cette
histoire m des héritiers ça nous pousse
aussi à être des bâtisseurs en ne
perdant jamais de vue la portée morale
et politique de la droite
notre ancrage notre identité singulière
alors oui je crois à une droite
authentique une droite authentique bien
dans ses valeurs vient dans son histoire
mais aussi bien dans son époque qui
n'est pas l'ennemi du progrès qui
travaille au renouvellement des
pratiques politiques et à mieux gérer le
pays certes mais qui plus que tout
défendre une certaine idée de la france
alors la droite elle est là elle est bel
et bien là elle est ici au parc floral
avec ses alliés du centre
c'est une droite fidèle à ses idéaux
ouverte sur un monde nouveau
une droite forte et conquérante qui
n'est pas celle du repli et de la peur
et vous en est l'exemple vivant alors
à tous ceux qui vous disent le clivage
droite gauche n'existe plus
répondez-leur qu'il y à des français qui
sont plus attachés à la liberté qu'est
l'égalitarisme
il y à des français qu'ils préféreront
toujours la responsabilité individuelle
à la culture de l'excusé il y à des
français qui comme l'écrivait françois
mauriac crois en l'homme
il y à des français qui pensent que la
sécurité est la première des libertés
il y à des français qu'ils défendent
l'indivisibilité de la république avant
tout sans aucune compromission possible
avec les communautarismes
il y à des français qui ont la passion
de l'europe en même temps que la passion
de la france
il y à des français qui croient que seul
le das réformatrice peut résoudre les
problèmes du pays
alors ces français ils sont de droite et
du centre droit
c'est comme ça c'est culturel c'est leur
histoire
c'est familial c'est leur caractère et
ça ne changera pas
[Applaudissements]
alors il nous appartient de reprendre le
flambeau il appartient avec françois
baroin de relever l'étendard il nous
appartient de poursuivre cette histoire
à l'heure où la république après cinq
ans de quinquennat socialiste est
menacée plus que jamais elle est menacée
par les mouvances terroristes qui ont
déclaré la guerre à la civilisation a
les mêmes menacés par la montée des
communautarismes qui fracturent la
nation mais aussi par l' influence des
fossoyeurs de l'école de la république
du mérite et de la réussite par la
tyrannie de l'égalitarisme par ceux pour
qui justice rime trop souvent avec
laxisme par les coupables obsessionnel
qui à coups de repentir permanent oppose
les français les uns aux autres au lieu
de les rassembler par les partisans du
relativisme et du multiculturalisme qui
disent qu'il n'y a pas de culture
française et qui nous font grandir dans
l'oubli et le mépris de nous mêmes
balayant l'esprit français sa grandeur
alors oui il nous appartient aujourd'hui
de relever le flambeau de reprendre
l'étendard de relever la france est de
redonner espoir aux français nous nous
serons toujours aux côtés de tous ceux
qui travaillent qui entreprennent qui
n'avait qui créent de tous ceux qui
prennent des risques et de ceux qui font
de la liberté
le socle de notre société
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'union de la droite et du centre
qui nous rend fort pour faire gagner
notre projet pour la france pour faire
gagner la france
les chers amis nous avons une immense
responsabilité
cette responsabilité c'est de créer les
conditions d'une véritable alternance
l'enjeu est de taille ce qui se joue
dans un mois c'est dessiner la france
que nous voulons pour les cinq années
qui viennent et rien ne serait plus
dangereux que de laisser en marche seul
face aux extrêmes notre pays est
profondément fracturé et on voit sur
beaucoup de points je ne sais pas si
vous avez remarqué et le au silence
complice de monsieur mélenchon on voit
sur beaucoup de points
les extrême gauche et l'extrême droite
ce convergent alors vous l'avez vu vous
l'avez entendu les français ont exprimé
comme jamais leur colère leur méfiance
et leur désenchantement aux dernières
élections au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle 45 % de nos compatriotes
ont voté pour les extrêmes cette colère
cette défiance désenchantement nous
voulons y répondre nous devons y
répondre
il est vrai que le front national ne
sort pas grandie c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire de cette campagne
présidentielle avez vous vu le
calamiteux débat du deuxième tour eh
bien le front national il ya montré son
vrai visage
le visage d'un parti qui se nourrit des
problèmes mais qui n'apportent jamais
aucune solution
alors il faut juger le front national à
ses actes le front national passe sa vie
à dénoncer dénoncé dénoncer et dénoncer
constamment le situation mais quand nous
nous proposons des solutions
ils votent toujours contre contre
l'interdiction de la burqa contre
l'interdiction des sites internet du
violent qui appellent à la haine contre
le fichier européen des passagers
d'avion qui permettrait de traquer les
terroristes et quant à strasbourg au
parlement européen on vote pour durcir
les contrôles aux frontières des
migrants et bien madame le pen n'est pas
là mais c'est normal c'est normal au
fond parce que s'il n'y avait plus de
problème il y aurait plus de fn
dites le autour de vous dites le à tous
ceux qui sont tentés le front national
c'est le parti qui vit de votre mal-être
mais qu'il n'y apporte aucun remède
efficace
le party kele solution crédible concrète
c'est nous vous le savez tous ici
prenons un seul exemple la sortie de
l'euro la sortie de l'euro serait une
catastrophe d'évaluation de notre
monnaie inflation hausse des taux
d'intérêt la ruine pour des millions de
français et la fermeture des frontières
aux produits importés
nous exportons nous exposerait à des
sanctions qui frapperait tous les
secteurs qui exportent de l'agriculture
à l'industrie
le programme du front national nous
conduirait à la faillite et au chaos
redite le redis que le sang cesse dans
cette élection législative
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quant au programme dans marche
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que ce
n'est pas le nôtre
et je rappelle pour ceux qui n'ont pas
complètement compris les dernières les
dernières séquences politiques que le
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron défend
le programme en marche et le programme
en marche et celui que nous combattons
depuis des mois nous le combattons parce
que ce programme n'a pas le courage
réformateur nécessaires pour lutter
contre le fléau du chômage nous le
combattons parce qu'il va porter une
nouvelle atteinte au pouvoir d'achat des
français qui sont déjà écrasés d'impôts
qui n'en peuvent plus du matraquage
fiscal qui s'est abattue sur eux pendant
cinq ans avec françois hollande nous le
combattons parce qu'il n'a pas la
fermeté indispensable en matière de
lutte contre le communautarisme et
l'islamisme radical
non le programme en marche ne permettra
pas de redresser le pays
le programme de redressement c'est le
nôtre et nous allons nous mobiliser jour
après jour jusqu'au 18 juin
c'est quand même une date très
symbolique ça motive
nous allons nous mobiliser jour après
jour jusqu'au 18 juin pour le défendre
parce que nous ne baissons pas les bras
parce que nous ne baissons pas la tête
parce que c'est ça toute la noblesse de
la politique se battre pour ses idées se
battent pour la justice pour la liberté
pour la valeur
[Applaudissements]
alors oui nous nous voulons restaurer
l'autorité de l'état et de la loi la
majorité pénale à 16 ans le
rétablissement des peines planchers la
suppression des réductions automatiques
de peine
la fin de l' immigration incontrôlée
nous nous voulons plus de sécurité et
réaffirmer l'unité de la nation
nous voulons une lutte impitoyable
contre le terrorisme l'expulsion
automatique des étrangers liés à des
réseaux terroristes
l'inculpation des l'inculpation des
fichiers s radicaux pour intelligence
avec l'ennemi la dissolution des
mouvements salafistes la déchéance de
nationalité pour les français
parti faire le djihad nous nous nous
battons aussi sur le terrain pour
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
qui n'est pas négociable sur le
territoire de la république
nous nous voulons plus de pouvoir
d'achat pour les classes moyennes et
populaires
le retour des heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées pour valoriser ceux qui
travaillent avec nous le travail paiera
plus que l'assistanat
nous voulons la baisse des charges la
baisse de l'impôt sur le revenu pour
tous les ménages grâce à la réduction de
la dépense publique
la revalorisation des petites retraites
en un mot des mesures de justice
le projet du gouvernement vous le savez
c'est dès juillet l'augmentation de la
csg
nous nous y opposons résolument on n'a
pas fait suffisamment de couches d'impôt
qui va en payer cash les conséquences
tous ceux qui gagnent plus de 1200 euros
par mois avec françois hollande ont été
riches à 4000 euros avec en marche
c'est à partir de 1200 euros
alors revenons aussi un peu à l'urgence
sociale de la france l'urgence sociale
de la france c'est la lutte contre le
chômage et non contre le chômage nous
n'avons pas tout essayé
nos voisins ont réussi à atteindre le
plein emploi
il nous faut le courage de faire comme
eux
c'est pourquoi nous avons gardé lé
audace réformatrice de notre projet
présidentiel sur les retraites
l'assurance chômage la baisse des
fonctionnaires pour baisser les impôts
et les charges
c'est comme ça que les autres pays
européens ont relancé la dynamique
d'embauché attirer les entreprises sur
leur sol et vaincu le fléau du chômage
la tisane dans marche ne suffira pas
[Applaudissements]
la priorité de la france c'est aussi la
sécurité
j'étais hier place de la chapelle une
zone de l'endroit en plein paris dans la
capitale de la cinquième puissance
mondiale où les femmes n'osent plus
sortir de chez elle parce que les hommes
les harcèlent en permanence les insultes
et les agressent une zone de non droit
où l'égalité femmes hommes et piétiner
ou la liberté de circulation est
restreinte ou les trafics en tout genre
fleurissent en toute impunité ou les
migrants chère natasha bouchard dorment
partout dans la rue où les commerces
ferment une zone de non droit où l'état
ne fait rien mais il ya combien de place
de la chapelle sur le territoire
français j'attends pour les français
j'attends pour ces français c'est
française
harcelés au quotidien qui demande à
vivre chez eux dans la tranquillité que
l'état prenne enfin ses responsabilités
et assurent la sécurité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous le voyez notre projet il n'est pas
angélique
il est lucide il a le courage la vérité
et c'est le véritable projet de
redressement du pays
alors mes chers amis nos candidats vous
en avez vu un petit échantillon
nos candidats ont beaucoup d'atouts pour
remporter les législatives
ils ont le bon programme mais ils ont
aussi le renouvellement la compétence
l'ancrage dans les territoires
l'alliance de la droite et du centre
alors chez nous il ya quelques règles et
elles sont pratiquement partout
respectée chez nous pas de parachutage
pas de débauchages pas de marchandage
et c'est comme ça qu'on a les meilleurs
candidats
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nos candidats ils ont un visage le
visage de ces femmes et de ces hommes de
france que vous venez d'entendre nos
candidats ils portent notre projet ils
le défendent bec et ongles sur le
terrain au plus près des françaises et
des français
ce sont eux qu'il nous faut demain sur
les bancs de l'assemblée nationale
[Applaudissements]
alors mesdames et messieurs mes chers
amis je vous le demande je vous le
demande instamment c'est cette voie
d'une droite authentique que nous devons
porter haut et fort avec fierté sur tout
le territoire dans les semaines qui
viennent au plus près de nos concitoyens
en porte à porte en réunions
d'appartement en réunion publique en
phoning c'est une question d'énergie
c'est une question d'envié c'est une
question de sincérité
c'est une question de conviction c'est
notre combat le combat qui nous unit le
combat pour la france que nous voulons
la france que nous aimons la france que
nous défendons
alors andré malraux le grand andré
malraux
le grand défenseur de la culture
française disait le caractère c'est la
vertu des temps difficiles
alors quand une femme a du caractère on
dit souvent qu'elle a un sale caractère
quand l'homme a du caractère on dit
qu'il a de la personnalité
moi j'assume on va avoir du caractère on
va avoir du tempérament
on va s'engager un pendant ces
législatives et on va les gagner
on va gagner pour la france on va gagner
pour le français dit république et vive
la france
[Applaudissements]